hey everybody and welcome to a strong
wild ride with stevo we've got bradley
martin this week who i've met a bunch of
times now while filming with steve will
do it and this guy's a bodybuilding
sensation he's been a fitness trainer to
the stars i mean the guy's amazing and
you know what else is amazing door dash
it's the most convenient delivery
service for whatever you need if you
want to get a meal from your favorite
restaurant any kind of uh supplies from
the grocery store your whole grocery
list who cares you get on doordash and
it's coming straight to you so you don't
have to waste your time worrying about
anything but what's important and if you
go and download the doordash app and
enter the promo code stevo they're gonna
hook you up on your first order man i'm
talking 25
for orders of 15 or more and that's up
to a 10 value and zero delivery fees
when you're just getting the most
convenient delivery service on top of
that telling you doordash is the way to
make life simple and get what you want
and what you need when you want it when
you need it so one more time let's go
and download the door dash app and enter
the promo code stevo you can get
whatever you want delivered
quick and easy and you'll get that
killer deal on your first order so
hook it up with doordash now let's get
into it
yeah this is actually funny as [ __ ]
right now
this thing i'll be dying
this is going to drive me what do you
want me to do
just try it closer
ladies and gentlemen bradley martin yeah
so have you met scott randolph several
times yes at the house paul briskey up
at the front yeah we met for the uh the
the chips the the hot sauce pothole
destroyer yeah we bought clothes that
we're gonna put it up uh steve's butt
yeah
well before steve got there before that
yeah right yeah and i knew right away it
was a terrible idea yeah you didn't want
to go for it yeah you were bro you
talked to modern i knew it was a bad
idea just to even show up at my house
no no no i mean that
that's always questionable but like i
knew for sure the hot sauce thing he was
not he was not gonna do i was like
there's no way steve's doing this right
for sure i felt a little bit bad after
that one um well your body like you're
so bad yeah
i i felt bad like oh dude you know i
didn't tell him what the idea was and i
ambushed him with some butt play stuff
yeah it was a lot
you're like come over here we're gonna
we were like one dildos up your [ __ ]
for this video
yeah dude it's gonna be great
um but yeah sir so dude thank you for
doing this absolutely and um the first
thing i want to tell you is that uh in
all of our interactions now we've like
we've made like a bunch of videos with
steve we'll do it yeah for all of our
channels individually you post it he
posts i post it yeah it's been great
like we've made a bunch of great content
but
in these
scenarios where we're shooting
like the i pick up on from like steve's
video like they're always always like
making jabs at you and this yeah
and so like i show up to the to the mix
you know and we're filming and i start
like taking jabs at you yeah people love
it people love taking jobs but you can
[ __ ] up everybody that takes jabs at you
yeah but that's not what it's about okay
i just i feel self-conscious because i
feel like you know we just met i'm like
just you know just showed up in the mix
and i'm just like i think it's okay to
like talk [ __ ] on you you know and like
would you say i mean i was lying like um
the last time i got together i was like
are you on steroids yeah
yeah they put it in the video and then
like
steve will do it he's like do this intro
and i'm like i'm with steve we'll do it
and and like whoever you know it's like
insulting and like i just felt like it
wasn't my place to
to do that even though it's the vibe of
the videos and it happens all the time i
wanted to acknowledge
that uh [ __ ] what am i doing like who am
i to do that yeah i mean i don't i mean
i don't really mind it man it's i know
it's part of like the comedy at least in
the bits even specifically with steve
like
people will come up to me and ask me
like oh does this stuff actually bother
you it's like none of it bothers me like
steve's like family to me it's like a
brother to me so i know that it's all
for the bid right and you guys know each
other for a longer time so yeah develop
that rapport yeah you know like i just
showed up in your videos like super
recently and like yeah so i just felt
like i owed you that to acknowledge that
uh i'm a [ __ ] face for doing that oh i
don't care man all right i think it's
funny okay cool man i i just kind of
learned i've been on the internet for so
long now and i mean i know you get this
too like i just try not to take myself
that serious right because like if you
take yourself really serious all the
time it just you're not gonna have fun
with it sure you know um i can't wait
this isn't my waters
what do i do with my [ __ ] that's
gotta be here it's probably probably one
of the ones
is not open oh cool yeah
sorry dude okay so um
[ __ ] man we just watched uh bradley
martin before they were famous
on the on that channel and you've got to
be the only person who's ever been on
that channel who like
you know emailed them answers to the
questions emailed to me that's what they
said in the video they were like he said
these are verified like that he went
back and forth with you and that you you
helped him kind of
get the information right he's an
[ __ ]
he wasn't supposed to say that what the
[ __ ] are you talking about
i'm completely unaware of that you were
nice enough to answer questions via
email you were nice what
what's this channel so we can do before
they were famous no i know the channel
but i don't ever remember answering
questions yeah like unless like someone
on my team did it he was like he says he
was kind enough to answer
uh questions via email and he got very
personal with us saying talking about
his anxiety being so bad that he had to
like go to the hospital for anxiety and
i think the implication was that that
was
personally emailed as like special
information directly from you oh
interesting i mean i do deal with
anxiety but i i mean my team would know
that like if they had to answer those
emails right and i've talked about it
tons of times on the internet like i'm
not right i'm not like closed off to it
you know they made it sound like they
had this yeah yeah i mean i mean maybe
but i don't i don't directly remember
sending off an email but i mean maybe
you know who knows i mean i like that
channel i'd check it out so i don't want
this to come off like i'm bad-mouthing
no no that that guy's cool he's done i
think he's done a few different ones and
then the mccreading guy he did another
one where he's like before i was a drug
dealer or something
like a
yeah after the steve will do a joke so
before there was one and then there was
like the steve will do a joke and then
he made a follow-up
um like before he was a drug dealer he's
like yeah he's a cool guy he's emailed
me a bunch of times
do you do you give him answers
i mean that video was like three years
old so who knows maybe it's closer to
four years old and they kind of listed
all these people that you've collabed
with yeah ah [ __ ] i gotta go watch that
yeah
i mean it was interesting it wasn't like
in any way like disparaging it was cool
yeah and um you know they said that he's
collabed with like
you know they showed you with joe rogan
with uh
um
and then all of a sudden we
we stopped like trying to prepare to
talk to you and we were just talking
about vitaly because he's so interesting
vitaly yeah
yeah i don't know what happened to that
guy have you been in touch with him i
haven't talked to him for a long time
yeah yeah i think i the last time i saw
him was like
at a at 11 in miami like
looked like he was like not doing too
well
yeah had like a at like a table
right but all i i mean the last thing i
heard of him was like i think everyone's
seen that stuff on like tmz where he's
like he hit a woman or something right
right he's not still in jail is he i
don't think so i don't think so i think
maybe he's just
avoiding the internet probably because
of that stuff i mean right that's a
serious i think it was like a serious
thing he beat up a random woman that was
running or some [ __ ] jumped out of some
bushes yeah um
how do you become
like
a celebrity fitness trainer
is that because it's a funny question
but is it like because you're in
woodland hills and everybody's in there
and they want to come to your gym it's
definitely not how you become a
celebrity just because i'm in william
hills no like i mean it my whole life
has been about the gym and training and
it's what i love the most
um
why because it's an outlet for like your
anxiety yeah because you just always
like body sculpting no it it's
definitely much deeper than just trying
to look a certain way like it started
you know
because of i would say
um my own acceptance of myself and being
good enough and it kind of related to my
father my father passed when i was
really young he took his life when i was
six and since then i kind of just
struggled with
feeling like i was good enough in the
gym when i found the gym and i was also
a really angry kid
and when i found the gym around like 15
and also sports and stuff but when i
really started training
i uh i realized how much it actually
relieved
just my my mental because i was
constantly thinking about these things
and i was constantly kind of just upset
about my situation like i didn't deserve
to be in this situation and the gym was
the one thing that like while i was in
it and i was doing it everything kind of
like
you know disappeared a little bit so i
was like oh i like this feeling almost
like a drug addict like i want more of
this i want more of this and uh i just
that's how i just got addicted to it
because it was like an escape
so becoming a celebrity trainer or
whatever you call it
uh
it just i think that happened over years
of just trying to
be on social media you know and then and
then being in the right place at the
right time and meeting certain people
and
being able to develop relationships of
you know celebrities or people who are
like hey i need advice on this or that
or diet or supplement stuff and then
it's kind of like got me into that lane
but it's definitely not because i'm in
woodland hills i'd say
i'm in woodland hills because i was able
to be there first you know what i'm
saying yeah who was the first person i
reached out to you that you're like holy
[ __ ] this guy wants me to train him or
work out with them
um the first person that i actually ever
trained in the industry was uh tyler
perry and this was years ago and that's
how you got the partners movie
yeah that's hot yeah so that's how i was
in like two like medea movies and then
uh well the second one actually he
wanted like a bunch of influencers to be
involved in it too because that's when
like
i think he also understood the power of
social media and wanted people to be
involved in it on that on that aspect
and um
i actually like hit up a lot of the
people who are in that movie like fousey
was in it yeah my other my other buddy
bro science people that were my friends
i was like yo you guys he's looking for
these people and i knew he got pretty
jacked
yeah right i helped him because of him
yeah
he he got really jacked actually yeah
like and that guy's been through so much
man
so many ups and downs he's like he was
like the king of the internet on youtube
at one point he he was definitely
crushing it and then when he like gave
away his youtube channel to a fan or
something what did they yeah he gave his
youtube channel away to like someone in
the audience and then like his friend
and then someone else was running and
then he took it back and he's just gone
through a lot of different phases right
i mean
i know he deals with
like literal like conditions where he
needs medicine and he he'd come off at
times and then i think he felt like he's
completely good but then something would
happen and
uh he i don't know he would just kind of
go through it you know he's a great dude
really good dude he's just he's been to
a lot yeah no i i get that
um i feel like training people in the
gym like people tell you their secrets
while they're working out like you're
kind of like oh my god yeah i know
everything about everybody
i know everything about everyone
yeah like everyone man dude so um i just
got a new publicist yeah and and the guy
out of the gate is just destroying it
he's just pulling [ __ ] off left and
right and he just told me that he has
secured for me
uh i don't know if i'm even supposed to
say this but uh a four to six page
feature article in men's health
what
that's right ladies and gentlemen i am a
picture of men's health you know why
because i use athletic greens every
single day when i wake up i drink a
bunch of water and i mix in a packet of
athletic greens ag-1 and that fills in
any gaps in my diet plus i can have it
on an empty stomach and i don't have to
worry about that like a lot of
multivitamins create problems
not this it's got 75 different vitamins
and minerals it's loaded with greens
it's all whole food sourced it's got
probiotics it helps with
digestion and gut health and i mean dude
i love it and i want you to try it too
plus if you go to athleticgreens.com
stevo you get
five of these travel packs for free and
i don't go anywhere without my travel
packs plus you get an immune supporting
entire year supply of vitamin d and you
just try it because it is so tasty and
delicious it's just a great way to start
your day and to get all the nutrients
and vitamins that you need i'm telling
you athleticgreens.com
stevo for five of these packets and a
whole year's supply of vitamin d
and wait until you taste how delicious
it is and what an epic way to start your
day so yeah dude thank you athletic
greens i love you now let's talk about
men's health
yeah hey how the [ __ ]
stop do like
why would you be in men's health well
because i i you know used to be a
disaster and oh
okay that makes sense i i take care of
myself i you know
care about certain stuff but you also
get [ __ ] things jammed into your
spine and that's true too right get
vasectomies
yeah it's very yeah no that's cool i
love it a double life i like to be a
conscious person do the right thing yeah
take care of myself and at the same time
i'm
flying reckless do you want to take trt
for this men's health i
i mean
my shoots for this is going to be you're
going to be on the cover i don't think
the cover i think it's just a four to
six page article yeah
but um i'm gonna have a photo shoot in a
hair less than one month
how in shape can i get
i mean
[ __ ] that's kind of like not eat like an
[ __ ] and do you train have you been
training consistently at all is this all
really but i like i have the type of
like
body or whatever where like if i really
put effort into it i get results pretty
quickly do you think you'd have enough
time to like try to try to train every
day at least for an hour i think so yeah
yeah i mean you definitely see some
improvement
yeah for the for the men's health thing
but if i train we leave town tomorrow
for a tour
i'm going to bring my perfect push-ups
on on tour there's going to be
and pull-ups are actually amazing yeah
if you could do that that because i
imagine they're not going to they'll
probably have you in shorts or
i don't know it's like the eating is
hard though right especially on tour
like how do you usually eat on tourists
eating is the hardest part yeah that's
hardest part getting in shape period
isn't that like 80 of it oh this is so
funny everyone always says it's like 80
20 is like
each one is like 100 but to be fair
like if you are just training and you
eat like [ __ ] all the time you're not
gonna like see that result depending
genetically like how much body fat you
hold or how hard it is to stay lean
right right so you will see an effect
like if you just ate a ton of food like
you're gonna build muscle you're
probably gonna build some fat
um if you ate the right amount of food
you're gonna look more how you want to
but it's funny when people say that
because
it's
it's a hundred each i can't it's hard to
say like oh it's 80 this 80 percent that
10 20 whatever but
they're both equally important
but i i will say you cannot outwork a
shitty diet so yeah if you if you train
all the time you train all the time you
turn on the time and then you just eat
like [ __ ] all the time you're you just
run in circles scott's like [ __ ] that's
so nice
like
it's it's like here's the deal right
here
no i'm not i feel like i ran five miles
i don't know what's going on
all the time oh man i swam like this
many miles like
i mean here's the
yeah that's not that bad though
but you can still be healthy right like
even if you're somewhat overweight or
like out of shape as my people might
perceive it you could still be healthy
because you're getting enough exercise
granted certain foods are going to be
more detrimental to your health than
others right so you always want to try
and eat cleaner but yeah if you want to
look a certain way for like something
like that you do have to focus on your
diet otherwise like
you're not going to see big time the
changes like physically i can only eat
half of my shrimp burrito
the shrimp isn't even that bad okay but
tortilla is it like the the tortilla
wrap is not good tortilla maybe and like
the chips and you know but if you work
out for like an hour a day like who
gives a [ __ ] right yes you said you
can't outwork and [ __ ] it depends i said
that he looked at my stomach
that depends honestly like i saw his
eyes i caught him it's like looking at
chick's tits he just looked at my
stomach
but i really mean this though like you
do you do kind of have to focus on that
like if you're not focused on what you
eat or or exercise like trying to
because everyone's so uniquely different
it's it's hard for me to say this is one
way right isn't it true that you can
also like
look like you're in shape and just not
be [ __ ] healthy at all because i had
a doctor
tell me that i'm what's called skinny
fat
where he says what that means is that
you don't appear to be fat but you've
got like fat on your organs yeah fat
within like in in between and around the
organs and like located in certain areas
where like it's more unhealthy
right than just having fat overall
what's the difference between white fat
and brown fat
so brown i believe is the fat that's it
can be
burned more quickly which
burning fat is you actually shrink fat
cells
right because fat actually never you
don't like lose fat you know you like
bitcoin
no no you could lose that no like you
don't you don't actually this is the
[ __ ] thing about fat right
you can build fat cells your body can
make new fat cells but it can never get
rid of existing fat cells it only
shrinks them so when you lose weight
you're shrinking the fat cells wow but
they're still dormant they're still
there and they still have the ability
that's why people who are overweight and
they lose a bunch of weight it's harder
for them to maintain that way because
like their body sometimes can go back so
that's why like
one of the most important things i think
that we don't talk about at all to like
for like kids and like younger adults is
like try to eat healthier sooner but we
just feed kids [ __ ] and we like get
overweight like not that it's a terrible
terrible thing but you're setting
someone up for failure because like the
more fat cells you put on the more
you're gonna have for the rest of your
life you can't you literally cannot
destroy them there's certain like weird
drugs and [ __ ] that might be able to but
they're like a lot they're like really
what about like liposuction that's the
thing so like a lot of times when you
remove fat from certain areas
sometimes your body is it's all about
trying to stay the same maintaining
homeostasis so like it will like it
could put fat somewhere else on your
body it might just be weird oh yeah like
it wants to have the same count of cells
okay it's very weird have you ever had
this dog's so dope
oh my god
have you ever had a period where
you just fell off and just like exercise
wise yeah
no
no for how long
for how long what since you're 15 years
old yes 17 like since then you've never
fell off you work out how many days a
week normally every day even but you're
traveling all the time too like how do
you so maybe i'll miss one day that's
probably it are you beating yourself up
on that day you're like [ __ ] i didn't
work out today no because i'll tend to
so the days that i if i'm not training
i'll i'll try to be much better on like
eating my eating habits so like because
then you kind of gauge like your
activity right if i'm not like crushing
it in the gym i know i maybe i just
don't need as many calories because i'm
not working as hard i'm not expending as
many calories since you were or whatever
since you were younger like how has
because you're pretty cute in on the
science of like training and what to eat
and what to do and i imagine that's
changed a lot since you started like
were you doing things kind of wrong at
first and you know um
man
i don't know it's necessarily wrong i
always had like a pretty good like basic
understanding of stuff
uh actually you know what i can tell you
guys a story so
no i did do things wrong um i over did
things in the beginning let me this is
actually a real true story when i was 18
years old
uh this is soon after 17 when i got like
really crazy invested into the gym i
understood more about training
before i understood a lot about exercise
excuse me excuse me diet in relationship
to training so i knew so much about
training that's what i got into first
so 17 to 18 when i was 18 i moved out i
lived up in cal state uh
sacramento state cal state whatever
anyways
i lived there and i was so
this is like my second year into like
really consistent training and i was so
crazy about my activity
where like to the point i go to class
hated school dropped out by the way i'd
go to class and then i'd go to like the
wreck gym
and then
every night at seven i would go out on
the american river up by sac state i
don't know if anyone was in the area and
i would do sprints on the american river
and like for you know i don't know like
wind sprints where i pick a thing and
run to it and then i'd like ride my bike
to a 24-hour fitness like two miles away
and i would like do the car this is real
[ __ ] i would do the cardio for 45
minutes after this was after all this
[ __ ] and i'd work out for an hour and
then i would ride my bike back and
continue my night but i had like a real
actual like body dysmorphia issue i
would go home then anytime i would eat
i would
like feel like okay i gotta i gotta do
curls i gotta do push-ups i had like a
real a real like ocd issue i don't know
exactly what it was but i'm talking
about to the point where i ate anything
i would get on the floor and start doing
push-ups like a psychopath and anyways
the reason why this is significant
is because it got to the point where i
had zero sex drive
like my sex i was completely gone like
to the point where i had i had a
girlfriend i had her come over and my
dick is just
soft
i gave myself like a legit hormone
imbalance
and that's when
around like almost 19 years old
i learned so much about hormones about
dieting about nutrition and i and i
fixed myself over the course of about a
year
but i'm pretty certain that i had
crashed my hormones because my my body
was so out of whack like i remember i
was waking up
four five six times every night peeing
and it's like my body's like eating
itself basically and that's why i have
to this is like a process that it goes
through like my body's like eating its
muscle when i'm peeing i'm peeing out
like this these i don't know
byproducts of that
why was peeing such a red flag for you
it couldn't have just been that you've
been drinking so much water because i
did drink a lot of water but i'm talking
about it was it was excessive the way it
smelled and i so i was i started reading
about all the stuff and i was like it
was excessive it wasn't like i'm peeing
like
twice i'm talking about every like 10
minutes i'm getting up in my i'm peeing
i'm like what the [ __ ] is going on and
the reason why it was a red flag for me
everything else was i mean i'm talking
about psycho like i would and so you
guys knew at the time i wasn't eating
enough like i was doing all that
activity every single day like
an hour of a gym and then
wind sprints for 30 40 minutes and then
riding the bike for 30 minutes and then
cardio for 30 minutes an hour of
training riding the bike back and then i
was eating like no fat cottage cheese
blueberries oatmeal no fat i didn't add
fat to anything i was i was my diet was
not conducive to this at all and i
learned all that obviously after the
fact but i got to the point when i was
like this is a major red flag not even
the peen was like it was tripped me out
because i was like i can't sleep and
this is causing me stress
but when i had my girl come over my
dick's like
that was like what the [ __ ] is going on
this is at 18 years old and that's what
i learned so like you said that's when i
learned a ton about like hormones and
actually eating enough
because i was so psyched with the
training i knew about that first but the
diet and stuff like was how long did
that last for
it lasts for about like
i don't know maybe three three months
three to four months
no no that took me like that took me
like eight months to get back like i was
in that [ __ ] up headspace for like
three or four months and then i was like
then you know the girl thing i'm like
what the [ __ ] this is a problem
and then i talked to my doctor i
remember going to my doctor
and i was telling him and he looked at
me he was like what are you what have
you been eating because he could tell
like i look like
like malnourished in a sense and i was
super lean i had crazy ass i remember i
was so like obsessed with keeping my abs
and like like looking a certain way and
i checked myself like every [ __ ]
20 minutes in a mirror it was like it
was a real body dysmorphia problem
like a legitimate wow
and and it yeah it ended up being like
my dick didn't work so i go to my doctor
and he's like you need to start eating i
wonder why
now then there was my approach when i
was you know 17 18 years old
i honestly have no idea why i decided to
tell the story that you're about to hear
and i'm even more confused as to why we
didn't edit it out but
it's coming and you know what before
that i need you to understand how much i
love hellotushy i've always said it this
is my favorite sponsor of the wild ride
podcast and note that it is reckless for
me to single out one sponsor as my
favorite too bad i love hello tushy that
much they make bidets
and if you've never tried a bidet then
you don't know what you're missing if
you've never tried a hello tushy bidet
then i feel sorry for you and they've
got this new
tushy ace this is the most luxurious
bidet that you can possibly outfit your
toilet with it's got a whole toilet seat
with the remote control that just sticks
onto the wall magnetically and you push
one button and the seat warms up to the
temperature you want it to be after you
get done taking your dump you push
another button and you get this
refreshing
stream of water blasting onto your
butthole just it's like pressure
cleaning it totally free of poop and
after you get done blasting your
butthole with this refreshing stream of
water then you push another button and
a little blow dryer
blows your butt hole dry the tushy ace
is the most wonderful product
ever
and i already loved tushy so much now i
love them even more because of the tushy
ace and i think that you're still in
time for the holidays to buy a tushy ace
for your most beloved
loved one and
you can also get ten percent off if you
go to hellotushy.com
stevo i cannot
gush about this product enough it is my
favorite sponsor of the wild ride
podcast it's hellotuchy.com
stevo where you can get 10 off the tushy
ace and be among the first people to
ever even try it it's the greatest gift
you can give this holiday season the
tushy ace
yeah dude
now let me humiliate myself
whatever i was doing i managed one time
to blow two loads into
the same rubber
what i bought i burned this chick okay
and blue loading the rubber okay and
then just kicked it i didn't take it off
and then
and then i recharged and then boner
again blew a second load in there why
didn't you take it off why did you just
get a new one
i don't know i was chilling okay you
[ __ ] with the load in there i parked
it alone
wow then how long did it take for you to
[ __ ] again i don't know how long how
long has that grace period what's your
recharge yeah
i was 17. it's pretty something's pretty
good i was 17 years old i was very quick
on the reload like five minutes i mean i
don't know i've never been quick on the
relay i hope it wasn't more than ten man
yeah maybe five maybe ten maybe maybe i
was hanging out might have been the next
morning i saw that thing on and wow
hopefully not
a soiled rubber on for an hour i don't
know
[ __ ] dude we watched a movie and then we
got back into it
like
never publicly but um
but well here you go right
it's an exclusive who was that is that
girl does that
do you her name is meredith okay shout
out meredith yeah wow
meredith that's amazing i mean obviously
there's tons of girls named meredith
right um
but uh the people who i've told that to
and you know just in private settings
have never believed it they're like
that's not true
like i also have another question like
why was she okay with that that's like i
have a whole another like set up she's
like you're just you still have the
condom like was it like was she drunk
yeah i'm chilling no not aware that that
like was happening it wasn't even uh
that we weren't like drinking super
heavily
um
i had snuck out of my house that night
it was like a school night and i wasn't
supposed to be out and i just snuck out
of my bedroom window
and uh
did you not have a second time you're
like i gotta keep this morning i had a
whole pack with me i can't remember if i
had another economy or not or maybe i
didn't have another one i'm not sure
maybe you didn't maybe it's out of
necessity like i'll just keep it on i
still got a knife
did she know like was she like we're
gonna do this again with that one or i
can't i can't remember
you worked the first time i mean dude
i'm 47 now so this is 30 years ago yeah
and uh all i remember is just that i was
like i'm kind of proud of that like dude
exactly you're like this is like a stunt
it's like yeah
and then you went back to school and
told everybody this story is starting to
sound really not good no it's bad it's
really not that bad well i can imagine
kind of
you went back to school the next day
told everybody and they'd literally ask
you the same questions we just did right
now
i i can't remember that but i can feel
my face turning totally red right
now
meredith shout out
that sounds terrible yeah
wow two in the clip it's pretty narrow
[ __ ] so so tell me about your podcast
dude
um so my podcast is actually we do it
right back here i gotta have you on the
back of my house i was here when we
drank all the eggs yeah so it's called
the awesome yeah yeah my podcast called
raw talk i have a co-host it's a girl um
i i started my podcast actually years
ago almost five years ago like when i
first opened my gym but i wasn't able to
sustain it because like the but my
buddies that i did with at the time like
started doing other things and we got my
one of them got pregnant and
not not my buddy but his wife obviously
and then yeah of course and then moved
on and then it just i tried to do it by
myself and i realized like i i didn't
want to have to just rely on guests
um so then finding a co-host has been
like incredible because now we can just
like talk about anything without always
having a guest on you know because i'm
sure you understand like to have a guess
on every time like sometimes scheduling
can be [ __ ] crazy it's the most
anxiety-inducing thing man like uh dude
we don't have it i've got a book
somewhere yeah so how awkward asking
people will you do so now so now it's
like but see if you had your buddy right
you guys could talk about this is like
what what i plan to do because i know
that i know how this works in this
industry and how people are constantly
moving around it's hard to pin people
down sometimes
um
we'll like talk about training topics
and [ __ ] like that so we'll just find
like things that are also relevant or
conversation pieces that we want to talk
about um that's cool we did a live
podcast this last week in uh cancun and
we didn't have a guest and so what we
impromptu we did a butthole beauty
pageant
in here
is on the stage in cancun you did a
butthole beauty pack so so there's only
dudes
nice did they bend over yeah they bend
over they spread it spread good so how
do you how do you gauge the most
beautiful what are the categories of
don't know we look like colors the
audience like like cheered the bit the
best butthole based on
two people
one guy had it by a mile okay why what
did he have that the others didn't yeah
like what are we what's the gauge i just
like i don't know i mean it's a
subjective thing but it was the butthole
that spoke to me
you know when you see it
you're like that's the one
that's the one
i resonate with that bubble yeah have i
ever seen a butthole good it was just
cute
he had a cute bottle
he wanted some hot sauce for his
butthole and we shipped it out to him
already wow good for him
congratulations to him
his name was
corey
cody cody cody yeah that's good um yeah
didn't show uh
like
with steve will do it yeah like how much
time do you guys spend together like
like a lot right like you're in all of
his videos and [ __ ] yeah yeah recently i
had ben um he's i know he's gonna move i
think he's gonna move back out here for
some time
um not not la but i think orange county
where the rest of the guys are okay but
um yeah this month i just i had to make
sure i was here because of all the stuff
that i have going on with my company
roger with like a whole apparel brand um
and black friday is like one of the most
important times so sure it's like the
biggest sale
yeah nice dude so i just had to make
sure i was here but yeah we normally
film like
at least once a week
for sure but the last few weeks
the last two weeks we haven't just
because i've been back home
how do you feel about the way that he
just
recklessly throws money around it's so
fascinating to me yeah um
it's almost like the more money throws
around the more it's coming in kind of
it looks like what's the most like not
expensive thing but i guess what's the
most extravagant thing that he's given
you because i know he's giving watches
out he's giving just crazy yeah um
he gave me a sixty thousand dollar chain
wow yeah
we were at the show in uh in florida and
and he was like i want one of everything
for the merch and i was like cool
and then he's like is there a tip button
on here and i'm like nope i'm like [ __ ]
dude yeah he's like are you sure there's
no tip on him like there's not i can't
do it like i can't imagine the craziest
thing i've ever seen him do though was
we were in compton and he did we did
like a a giveaway thing where he's
basically giving away a ton of like um
you know like tablets yeezys like all
this expensive stuff to people who came
to like get and also free burgers
so but but this is the thing that was
crazy to me like yeah he gave all the
stuff away like oh it was like i don't
know maybe forty fifty thousand dollars
in like merchandise and then maybe five
to ten thousand dollars in like food
burgers and stuff
but when we went back to the place where
the restaurant were the burger people
right
he the bill was like
like five bucks and he wrote it in the
tip for like 13 grand or something oh no
no it's way more than that oh wow he
paid them fifty five thousand dollars
and then gave them like a some some
percent tip and it came down to seventy
thousand dollars
wow for something that probably cost
like
thirty eight hundred
yeah yeah like um 30 f maybe 5 000 or
something like that
70 like 77 000 on a receipt
with his amx and i was like what the
[ __ ] that was that was the craziest
thing i've ever seen him do like in one
like a one purchase but i've seen him
i've seen him spend way more money than
that of course but like it was just i i
had never just i've never seen someone
put that much like of a payment on you
know like a little card credit card
processor thing yeah i got to leverage
my [ __ ] yeah i was like i always read
you yeah i'm always like i declined like
yeah i was like honestly i was like
impressed by the amex i was like holy
[ __ ]
yeah i don't think amex has a limit i
think that's their deal yeah that one
that one the black yeah i don't have
amex but yeah he's the thing that i've
realized with steve is like he
he's not a dumb dude at all like he's
before he started doing all that stuff i
know that he had put stuff away in like
certain you know real estate in certain
investments
um and then he started kind of being
more reckless with like money for the
audience and for the fans um
and yeah i mean i think people it's a
part since it was a part of the content
it's like it gets people also more
engaged because like holy [ __ ] this is
crazy right so it does kind of come
around you know
does he ever say to you like look dude
just give away 50 grand like and you're
like nah that's you do it i don't want
to do it no no he it's not like that i
mean he's just he just does it you know
right yeah he's never like oh you got to
do this or whatever sure
he's not he's not that that kind of dude
can i pivot to your uh do you have like
a daily routine that you do every day
work out wake up at a certain time i
wish man lately i haven't because i've
it's been so much more like busy work
stuff but again i think it's just
because of this time of the month with
the whole black friday thing going on
but yeah my my typical routine like
outside of this month
would
i mean i'll normally wake up i'll i'll
go train fasted
uh which is like i won't eat before i
train why because you burn more fat no
not necessarily i just feel better that
way i've always kind of been more of a
minimal eater like i don't eat as much
as you probably think i eat
um i just functioned better like that i
feel a little bit more about eight times
what you would think i did no no it's
funny i eat less you probably do but i i
guarantee i ate less than what you guys
think i eat right and i've always kind
of been that way um so i'll go i'll
train and then i'll eat my first meal
afterwards and then what's what's the
first meal for you
ah omelette
no
so i was oh you like chipotle or
it's like a chicken and rice thing
mainly that that's your first meal it's
like a lunch yeah so is it like
intermittent fasting yeah essentially
that's exactly what it is i mean i've
done that for years but you don't call
it intermittent fasting right because
it's like i mean it is this is what it's
it's
so you start eating at like 11 and you
stop eating like six
no i did that i actually did follow
strictly
these protocols like intermittent
fasting which is like the windows eating
versus windows not
but then
i kind of just realized okay i just feel
better doing it this way not necessarily
stopping eating at a certain time
anymore like if i'm still hungry
even close to bed like i'll still eat
if i was really serious about
like trying to get a certain effect for
my body like if i wanted to get leaner i
was like okay i really want to do this
then yeah i will stop at a certain time
um just because i don't not necessarily
i'm worried about the time like it being
too late at night i'm just more worried
about just eating too many more calories
because like i'm like a snacker in the
middle like at night like maybe in the
middle of the night how many calories
you try to eat a day
um
i'd say typically it's probably like
thirty five hundred thirty thirty six
in a pound of fat is how many calories
a pound of fat
or how many calories is a pound isn't it
like 20 or what am i saying what am i
why am i nine calories
oh is that what it is i'm just trying to
think about like the daily limit like is
like 2 300 if calories like the average
person should be consuming you're just
completely making [ __ ] up right now
i'm not gonna lie right now you're
really [ __ ] me up right now but um
i'm trying to figure out what to do
were you trying to define how many
calories were in a gram of fat
i couldn't tell you where i was okay
i was like what no so
um scott was just hoping you'd pick it
up
you should have kept going with it i
would have sounded smart
i'm sorry you just threw me off um so if
you're looking for some sort of insight
into like calories this is what people
don't understand it's like some people
do it's very very simple
um you can literally go on google and
type in bmr which is basal metabolic
rate
and because this goes along with your
question you're kind of asking me
and it'll give you a number based on
like your age your height and your
weight right you'll get like a number
and that's your number that's like your
body's
how many calories your body burns just
like doing stuff normally day to day
like waking up
walking around doing activities your
body will burn this amount of calories
essentially right roughly
yeah rough i mean there's going to be a
like and then spectrum
exactly and then from there you kind of
add or you kind of
you're going to add some for activity
and then you may take away some for like
okay if i want to lose fat i want you
know what i'm saying if you want to add
even more if you want to build muscle
and then everyone is so obviously
different where maybe it's a little bit
more maybe it's a lot a bit more you
know or maybe it's a little bit less
okay to to figure that out but like a
lot of people don't know that like
really basic thing you could just google
that it's so simple and then just put in
your numbers and it'll give you the mmr
your bmr basal metabolic grade do you
have a special scale like a smart scale
no that's just stupid it's stupid yeah
okay do you train people uh to get ready
for boxing matches or mma fights not
necessarily but like i i'm sure that i
could like i wouldn't train them how to
strike but like for strength and
conditioning as far as like having you
know more power in the hips and probably
be more athletic in a ring i'm sure i
could train someone for that for sure
but like am i training somehow to fight
no no
you you own this gym it's close to here
yeah it's down the street it's like
seven minutes um
and uh
that's like a big that's how you said
that you put like three hundred thousand
dollars into the equipment there oh more
almost six hundred thousand wow yeah
what's the name of the gym it's called
zoo culture zoo culture yeah we're
looking at we're looking at actually
moving out of there like
asap into a bigger location it's just
been hard to find spots and then also
opening one in austin
it seems like the pandemic
like decimated the commercial real
estate market it seems like you could
probably find it yeah but you'd be
surprised actually how much stuff after
the fact that things are getting like
bought up quick
yeah almost as if like it [ __ ]
everyone over and then like all these
bigger people kind of bought everything
right that's what it looks like
in the area where i'm at it's like all
these spots
were like bought and then they're being
turned into big massive uh apartment
complexes
straight up they took everything well
like corporate offices are turning into
apartment complexes no like like
warehousing spaces yeah where i would
put a bigger gym they're converting
they're all just being blown down and
turned into giant apartment complexes
you could tell like it's all all these
things got [ __ ] and then everyone all
the big dollars came in and just took
everything and they're building like
yeah big money
that's exactly right so so when someone
gets a membership at your gym yeah
that's just they're just at the gym yeah
and then separate from that someone can
hire you personally no to train them no
no no no i don't train people anymore oh
you don't no i have zero time to do that
is there a time to do that yeah what
takes up most your time
running a business running the business
creating content running multiple
businesses actually creating content
supplement company
uh the podcast stuff obviously all this
production stuff the youtube two youtube
channels
um
i have a third there's like a
third-party company that i run
and then uh
i'm partnered in like a bunch of other
companies there's a there's a ton of
[ __ ] that i do what's the other third
what's the third party company that
you're running i can't explain that one
okay all right
everyone's gonna hear that on the
podcast and be like drug dealer
that's funny though that's gonna go
really well um
so when when you're cruising around with
uh the whole steve will do it crew and
everything everyone's getting all [ __ ]
up drinking are you drinking with them
no
you don't drink at all i drink every
once in a while like i'll have a drink
if like i'm chilling and we're going out
to celebrate something um
every once in a while i'll drink it's
very rare though i just i don't enjoy it
as much like
drinking's not really ever been my thing
like if i was ever gonna do something
i'd rather smoke a little bit of weed
you know or take some mushrooms or
something like that but i'm not really
big into drinking because
there's no like
real benefit from it like the biggest
benefit is like you can be a little bit
more relaxed and like you know maybe in
some circumstances like
not feel so
you know caught up in yourself because
you're drunk and you're more relaxed but
like
mushrooms are actually good for your
brain not on a not in a massive dose all
the time that's a problem right right
but there's some health benefits to it
and then smoking weed can be good and it
can be kind of if you're like not going
overboard with it you can be good but it
but alcohol just is poison it just makes
you not feel that great yeah like but
don't get me wrong i like to drink and i
like to celebrate i like to celebrate
things and i will have a drink but i'm
not like a big like i'm going to get
[ __ ] up and drink right you know
what is your
i mean you said how like you never
really like slipped but what is your
like sort of indulgent like tonight i'm
gonna like go to cinnabon or like
whatever like do you have anything like
that oh my god i mean i love
[ __ ] i ate shitty stuff all the time
talking about food right yeah talking
about food yeah yeah i love you
i love i love shitty food man i can't
lie like i just i just stay away from it
but
i like a cheesecake a lot that was a
little secret yeah i mean it's not even
a secret
yeah i'll tell you guys i'll tell anyone
i have a sweet tooth a big sweet tooth
i'll shout it from the rooftops yeah
yeah i love cheesecake yeah cheesecake
nice so
how many private jets have you been on
oh man
i don't know a ton you in the mile high
club
yeah
what's your uh what's your longest
distance because like a private jet to
vegas
is whatever
but like a private jet to abu dhabi is a
different story you go on a private jet
from la to new york that's like baller
yeah um
have you done it in miami no i've done
la to like
uh
like bahamas is that so this kind of
part yeah that's miami yeah
yeah so that's what nasa
yeah that's what like six hours five
hours yeah i mean i've been a [ __ ] yeah
a ton of private planes yeah have you
ever paid for one yourself or you just
oh yeah i paid for every time i flew to
steve i paid half the [ __ ] thing oh
really yeah
and then in the video he says that you
didn't yeah
exactly
everything
everything on those [ __ ] trips i paid
i paid all my [ __ ]
everything i paid half the [ __ ]
flights of those things i paid for the
hotel room and paid for his hotel room i
paid for everything and it was just a
funny joke
as a casual
you know a viewer
like he he always says yeah he didn't
bradley martin didn't pay for anything
bradley martin didn't you know yeah it
was his cap you you you paid for half
the 60 000 necklace he gave you no no
he did buy that for me okay yeah how old
are you
i'm 32 32. yeah jesus christ i'm 32.
you're like you're like three twice yeah
it's like i feel like a little child
next year i mean how long have you
worked out for like a day one time he
went to the doctor
and they're like you have no butt yeah i
hurt my knee like just running yeah and
they're like the problem is you have no
ass yeah you need muscle there to
protect yourself i'm just learning this
now
can you help him build a butt that's so
easy yeah what is it just like i can't
go up a step right now with my left hand
see this is the crazy thing about
working out like that's people don't
realize how it's you don't need to be
some big jack [ __ ] bodybuilder that's
not what it's about but like literally
protecting your joints and stuff as you
age it's it's [ __ ] essential
like it's gonna make you if your quad is
strong your calf is strong and like your
glutes and your hips are strong like
your knees are going to be safer your
hips are going to be safer your back's
going to be safer so if you just did
pull ups push-ups and squats
yeah you'd be [ __ ] solid yeah i would
probably do deadlifts pull-ups and
push-ups
personally
just because like the deadlift is where
it goes up off you're going to hit the
ball yeah the bar like this i see not
over your head straight from the floor
like up to your hip i see it's a big hit
hip uh
squats too though yeah do you get paid
for uh personal appearances and stuff
where it's like you're hosting the night
at the nightclub no i've never done that
never i've been offered [ __ ] like that
yeah do you do brand deals on like
instagram and stuff like nope no branded
post no
all every like all the businesses that i
have like is that's
that's been
good you know it's been good enough for
me because i'll tell you a story i
remember actually like years ago
um
way before i ever got like really really
popular on social media
i i remember asking
uh this kid who was sponsored by and he
was like
he was a competitor and he was sponsored
by a company
that uh a guy who's a friend of mine i
just want to say these names of the
company because like i don't want to
cause any issue with them um but he was
sponsored by this company and the guy
who owns the company was a friend of
mine
now obviously not then i didn't know him
well but i was a fan of that guy so i
asked my buddy who was like a part of
the company i was like yo uh like
i was like new in the industry i was
like oh i want to get sponsored like
would they sponsor me
and uh he was like nah like we're good
and i remember being like what the [ __ ]
like i was so mad oh yeah and now from
that moment i was like [ __ ] these people
and i was i'm just gonna do it all
myself and that's when this was years
and years and years ago but that's when
i decided like i'm just gonna own all my
own [ __ ]
okay and i also realized like
on social media
it was because when i started on social
media like in the fitness industry just
to give you perspective on on instagram
in the fitness industry i was probably
the first dude ever with like 10 000
followers like i was back on instagram
from the beginning 2010 2011.
so i saw everything come up and i was i
remember watching there were certain
companies that like were born out of
literally instagram and they were
picking up all these athletes and
sponsoring all these people and i was
like wait like these companies are just
these people were
you know miles ahead follower wise and
the company kind of like was like okay
let's work with these people and the
company blew up and i remember seeing
him being like wait it's just like
but i was one of those people but i just
wasn't a part of that company and i
remember being like wait i can do this
[ __ ] of my own
yeah so that's and i just tried to
figure it all out and then i mean now i
just have so since pretty much the
beginning it's been like i just want to
figure it out for myself
so is it
how does the uh
like
the
content creation side of your business
compete with like the actual businesses
as far as like my attention it would be
the biggest thing
um
like today for example
i go to the gym and um there's so much
stuff happening
on the business side of things that like
i didn't actually get to get my work out
in today which is a part of not being
able to make a specific type of content
or
um
it's just really about like where i
could put enough energy because like you
to to be creative and to create
something new
you got to think about things right like
you got to have it come from somewhere
but if you're you're constantly focused
on like maybe this back end issue or
you know what's happening over there the
movement of the business here it kind of
can take you away so i definitely as
i've gotten more involved in a lot more
stuff it's it's harder to find time to
like sit and just be creative on like
content and then you know also balance
all the other things so
i've i've just gotten better at you know
building out a team and trying to get
people involved uh with my companies
that are
you know creative that's like the number
one thing to try and find people who
work you work with you want to find
people who
are giving their ideas to things instead
of just doing things right i feel like i
have the the opposite
where it's like
you know i'm so just
so driven to like
be creative yeah like that gets all my
energy and and it's hard for me to
like
[ __ ] open my emails it's hard you
know like like they're on the
administrative side so i got to surround
myself with people who can do the
administrative administrative [ __ ] yeah
i mean it's a balance it's like having
both of those things like you you
definitely want to understand to what's
happening because like you also don't
want to be taken advantage of if like
things are happening i'm not saying this
happened to you but i know this could
happen to a lot of people if they're not
aware of what's happening on the back
end then like you you're not necessarily
knowing what's going on you know right
um so you have to kind of have i've
realized you got to kind of have your
hand in both things
yeah yeah and that's the craziest thing
on social media i think i don't i don't
think people on it get enough credit who
are doing at a high level because like i
think people view it just like you're
just posting content on the internet or
i'm just sitting here in a van talking
to you but for sure there's so much
other [ __ ] that goes on that's like [ __ ]
man i haven't i don't sleep great the
last like week i've been like stressed
out as [ __ ] about a lot of stuff but
it's like you wouldn't see that because
i'm not posting saying i'm super [ __ ]
stressed out about this right you know
you just see me trying to post something
about lifting a girl or doing some crazy
[ __ ] on the internet
yeah it's nuts man how uh
you know the how social media has
changed the landscape oh my god the
entertainment industry changed
everything yeah not just entertainment
like
e-commerce commerce in general like
entrepreneurs media it's changed the
entire [ __ ] world man and it's
there's it's a really massive
double-edged sword because like even
though this political [ __ ] and the
internet all this all this stuff is like
the way people receive information now
and like just once they hear something
they're like this is true like i wonder
how many people out there actually think
i'm a real drug dealer because steve
made a joke about it and then someone
says it in a comment and they really
like he's a real drugger it's like yeah
i'm not it's a joke but how many times
people see someone on the internet and
just based on the algorithm the way the
internet interacts with you in your
accounts like how you see information
and you're just like you see you're like
that's true that's true that's true
it's [ __ ] crazy like the internet is
wild
super wild man it's changed everything
it's changed the way like even dynamic
between like men and women and like
dating and it's [ __ ] right damn it's
[ __ ] crazy
yeah man
um
what uh
like is there anything that you're that
you're pushing to
do you have your own supplement line
yeah so i'm in the process right now
it's called origin subs but i'm in the
process right now of
rebranding it probably more closely
related to zoo culture
and then launching that over again um
the
raw gear is the main thing that i work
on like
every day like my focus is growing that
is is creating better items that's
that's apparel it's everything i'm
wearing yeah everything i'm wearing i'm
sick dude i like those sweats so this is
like yeah this is my number one this is
the thing that i work on every single
day no matter what you know we've we
just recently just to give you some
history like i
i had
i had been
selling things on the internet that i
really loved for a long time since 2015
is when i started the company but it's
only been about like
maybe 13 months since i rebranded it
from raw gear it always had this logo
but i rebranded it from bm figure which
is just like my initials you know what
i'm saying because i was just like when
i started i was just selling things that
i oh i like this you know when i wore it
i appreciate it so i maybe people would
buy it
um but it's evolved so much more just
over the last year i've involved a lot
of like influencers who are coming up in
the industry and it's like taking a life
of its own it's growing like at a crazy
rate so raw gear is the new name for
something that you've been doing
considerably longer yeah since 2015.
so it's called raw gear it's it's
lifestyle apparel shim apparel it's
there's there's weightlifting gear it's
everything do you have rodger.com yeah
rocky dogs that's where people go
together yeah roger.com yeah yeah dude
that's like my number one thing and then
obviously
um
opening up the bigger gym in la the zoo
culture and then also
looking to expand like nationwide we're
just trying to start with texas because
it's also a place i kind of want to move
to oh yeah okay yeah because california
is kind of interesting
very i
i love it don't get me wrong that's the
thing like i love it it's just like
i had some friends who came the visit
from some athletes a lot of athletes
would come and stay at my house here
yeah um so there's always people in here
like you saw some of them leave earlier
those two girls are from austin but
where we're going to open the gym at but
they went into a mall over here and then
they were like yeah you need the vaccine
thing and like they were trying to like
car i was like holy [ __ ] that's crazy
they're really doing that scott said
that he had got sushi yesterday and they
wanted a vaccine and a driver's license
wow and then i got ice cream and they
said the same thing wow
dude i'm going nowhere then i went to
the pizza joint
oh my god
so much like jesus christ for the guy yo
it's funny the guy who asked the most
about fitness stuff come on
no you're just like it's you you should
not maybe not eat as much [ __ ] i can't
help it dude it's fine i look i love ice
cream i love pizza i do it too yeah but
i can't tell it's just maybe not on the
same night
that's all i'm saying
like you know maybe maybe not every
night yeah yeah yeah you're just like
dude i love it too just like give it
some time we're alcoholics
it's [ __ ] hot yeah
we have super you know alcoholic
tendencies and it's fun addictive
approaches to everything that we do i
get it i understand as well you should
leave your vax card at home so they
don't let you in
yo that's a play
oh [ __ ] i forgot it oh i [ __ ] i forgot
it
can't get pizza
yeah but then you're outside be like hey
can you go in there and get me
yeah i'm just like jonesing outside
to go buy your iphone [ __ ] it's so good
scott was this guy was gonna try and eat
his burrito during the podcast yeah well
it's just because i've been taking
excedrin migraine and my stomach's a
little upset
[Music]
so you want to eat the burrito yeah yeah
yeah we got we got one for you too yeah
we got one for you oh yeah yeah man
let's shout out anything else that uh do
you eat do you eat on the podcast like
this i mean we have we did with t-pain
we ordered lobster oh see pain was on
here yeah that's literally yeah
yeah he's been like crushing it on like
doesn't he twist yeah he switches it up
yeah i don't i haven't i haven't seen it
but i've seen clips of him doing it on
the internet but apparently he's like
really successful at that
yeah he's he gave it the numbers yeah
yeah my instagram is bradley martin uh
my twitter is bradley martin my
snapchats bradley martin youtube podcast
podcast is raw talk that's actually the
number one thing i'd say that i'm really
heavily focused on growing at least on
social media right now and i love it
podcasting is by far my most favorite
type of content how long have you been
doing that now well so i said earlier i
i i had been doing a podcast not
consistently but about four years ago i
started it uh-huh and i did it for about
a year right and then i stopped for for
about a year and then this iteration
with the co-host this iteration with the
co-host uh four weeks oh okay cool yeah
so it's it's crushing it's doing really
well on youtube actually it's a smart
move to to do the no guest thing i think
your mom's house was saying they did
that at one time they're just for like
for the next year no guess it's just us
you got it i mean you build an audience
that doesn't need a guest yeah you gotta
do that because like i think i mean just
man that's interesting how many times
can you have a [ __ ] guess you can't i
mean i mean i guess if you're joe rogan
you could have i guess
everyone in the world [ __ ] he
probably is like the messages are like
probably 50 people trying to get in on
his pocket yeah yeah i mean without a
doubt i mean joe rogan's got to be the
one person that like he can rely on a
guest because like he probably has a
line the size of the earth right to try
and get on his podcast so
you know i mean we're not all joe rogan
all right so right i love joe rogan
though he's a dope dude yeah really good
guy he's an impressive man dude no doubt
all right do everybody follow bradley
martin listen to his podcast go to his
gym buy his clothing line thank you i
want to subscribe to his youtube channel
yeah all that [ __ ] all that [ __ ] dude
and try not to be such a [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah yeah yeah
yeah straight up that's good advice
that's really good a general message
and there you have it dudes bradley
martin what a rad bro i really do
respect that guy and for those of you
who are able to see on youtube
how about this [ __ ] tour bus
man dude
i told bradley we were going on tour i
didn't know we were going to be living
in this kind of luxury i mean
i want to spend the rest of my days
living on a [ __ ] tour bus just like
this dude and this toy bus is going all
over man if you live in america there's
a good chance i'm coming your way
ah i mean [ __ ] dude check out my tour
schedule this tour is going
off [ __ ] yeah love you guys man thanks
for sticking around woo